hallo hey hon hey that's my that's my
impression of your won most of Hawaiian
a lot of Hawaiian music oh wow it's your
friend in all the islands beautiful I
was in Hawaii a couple things I learned
yeah number one is beautiful number
crested yeah I'm going there every year
yeah you're not but carry on well if I
want to go on a vacation very easy I
gained three hours takes me about four
and a half hours to get there stop
fighting everything is smooth and easy
and guess what Hawaii's number one place
kill cuz there's no Isis there's no
terrorists this is correct
that's another that you just are there's
some Hawaiian SEP maybe they don't want
you on your waves all good baby that's
right and go on your way that's right
I'm not gonna go on that stay on the
land I say a guy like me because there
are big people there are big strong
people but they're all very very nice I
but I learned some stuff I took a
sailboat out there and there's no wind
so we used the motor thank God I'm not a
big I'm not a big sea guy I was like I
love the ocean not me who was all who's
all on the boat was your mom and
everyone just my in-laws my elbows and
hoes bro well I don't know it's on there
and a lot of kids but yeah I know you
mean but no it wasn't one of those it
wasn't one of those was a rap video
yachts with girls it wasn't a [ __ ] rap
video I wasn't the 2 Chainz dick suck in
the galley
there was none of the boys sucking off
the barnacles nope nope there was none
of that
it always suck in the squid alright
it's a family vacation huh it was a
family vacation and I saw we saw
dolphins and you always see dolphins
when you and everybody goes whoo now I
don't know if you know this but usually
people used to jump in the water and
swim around with the old dolphins and
about a hundred of them spinner dolphins
it's a bad idea
well the reason to bad ideas cuz do you
know why it's a bad idea
artsy Dolph no you know what they're
doing when they're when they're when
they're swimming like that and you see
them in the middle of avoiding tuna nets
and you don't become tuna no that's good
too but no no they're mating and also
gauge you know dolphins are one the only
gay animals that's true some of them can
be gay I jump in the water with your
rump but
not doing the dorsal fin your huh no
that's not it I've now I don't think
that's ever happened but I will say this
why then why do you not why do you not
mess with them when they're doing that
because there's babies cuz they're
sleeping
cuz half their brain is asleep they're
taking the rest and they just kind of
swim and half their brains awake have
their brains asleep now when you jump in
the water you can wake them up because
they're like I want to play with you and
they'll spin around you and they'll do
stuff cuz they're awesome
but you're waking them up so they were
like of a bullet boat every 20 minutes
comes and does this our dolphins aren't
gonna get sleep and it could cause some
issues some issues they get a little
feisty yellow crayon at night also the
dolphin so shut the [ __ ] and put on a
show for us humans I'm gonna make a tuna
sandwich idea shut the [ __ ] I don't care
if you're not getting your sleeve yep
you got a show on put a show on cuz I
want to be entertained for my eyes my
eyes are for five hours watching out
stupid fish dance
my eyes are bored with it with the waves
correct so you go ahead and jump around
me and I want to pay you cuz you feel
like a giant olive correct I want to
touch you giant olives this is Little
Mermaid [ __ ]
yup and maybe I'll ride your dorsal fin
wake the [ __ ] up flipper act is how
you're saying correct there's one reason
you're here on this earth to entertain
me that's it name another reason they're
on this earth well this woman said can I
jump in any way I don't care she goes
you can jump in now hold on see this
really is yeah hold on it's captain
captain turtle isn't her real name
Bryant cat called himself captain turtle
how old is he about my age does he
collect turtle he's a water baby
lady start like Turtles the surfer nope
calls himself captain turtle nope don't
know why yourself my real name is Brian
don't tell anybody I go I won't your
secret is safe with me
she was safe for me turtle here's the
thing kevinturtle kevinturtle said you
can jump in there absolutely gonna cost
you twenty thousand dollars what that's
the fine sir
oh I thought you've seen say that's my
feet that's that's a Hawaii doesn't [ __ ]
around if you jump in the water yeah I
think if I was like I didn't see the
[ __ ] dolphins that jumped ain't red
meat when you're bigger than all the
dolphins number one I want you to know
that you're bigger than I've ever seen
you number one I don't know what you're
doing doing a lot of heavy lifting yeah
you're a giant man and here's the thing
I
bigger than than all those spinner
dolphins so they're gonna be like who
the [ __ ] is the threat and they're gonna
come at you 63 I'm a killer well they're
gonna poke the sugar got my brown and
white killer whale yep you know what a
liver shot is cuz they do they do they
would that was [ __ ] her that's right
and guess who's not going in to guess
you know this is what you do or too big
to say that they're stupid dole beaks
and go be burnt
Steve Burns said that um you're never
you're never gehrig air than when you're
riding a dolphin he's alright two great
jokes it's like one you never gave them
when you're riding a dolphin he said and
there are two things I want to do before
I die one is catch a squirrel and the
other is when somebody dies I want to do
this with their eyes I wanna I wanna I
want to cover their lids okay and then
he goes ultimately I want to catch a
squirrel kill it and do that to its eyes
that's so funny that's eyes shout out to
Steve Byrne yeah [ __ ] dolphins oh yeah
dolphins will don't know [ __ ] so crazy
promise with you if you start drowning
you're taking everybody with you so I
can't save your dolphins I gotta be like
ah dude somebody get me a ring so I can
throw it out on the bessel around that
boat they took at the cabin on that
thing goes he goes listen guys we got
all kinds of stuff we've got a lifeboat
we got life vests we had their forty
nine people on here we got we got twice
as many life vests to grab one and then
we got rings and we got a desktop I mean
there's a lot of stuff I don't even know
I got no idea what a lot of this stuff
does it's so funny first aid I got no
idea so hold on guys out to sea too long
yeah that's forever it's forever
in fact my daughter goes how long till
we get there are we gonna get there soon
he goes nope got about two hours I was a
long for kid doesn't it's long for a kid
it's long for a kid but you know what we
went snorkeling
you stopped last northland yeah sea
turtles inning saw turtles swam with the
turtles swim kestrels parrot fish swam
with I saw big old moray eel my daughter
jumped on my back in a minute as we were
snorkeling she goes scream and jump them
but yeah yeah but animals are drawn to
me and I understand the eels yeah that
would be what it was
see that spotted one
I believe that's what it was spotted
Morton you know huh some guys saw a
goddamn a sea snake he said well that
guy's lying
hey he dug guy said he's a life a lie
yeah
was it the black and white one yeah my
father thousand caught a shark on video
your father lost elbow spoke on one reef
shark no they don't count
exactly yeah that's great now if you see
a tiger then catch and show a lot of
Tigers Peter attea on Rogen's podcast I
didn't swim from lanai and Maui batten
back in the nighttime because well tiger
sharks you can't [ __ ] through the tiger
man well monk seals there was a monk
seal washed up on shore it was like oh
my god it was alive I'm there monk seals
there 600 pounds and shaking of it they
just lie there
yeah monk seals are they they get they
get you locked up by tiger sharks oh
that little cutie thing wouldn't you
want to squeeze his little yeah look
very similar to him you do her in the
water you look like a giant she's a lot
of pokey I didn't some of the best food
though it dukes it was good I had a lot
of the Hawaiian sweet potato I had a lot
of coconut cream on some same at fish
curry food was good there I love Hawaii
many a vacation you need a vacay I was
thinking about that I know I was
actually relaxed I haven't taken a
vacation in how long I was like mmm yes
nice I didn't do a damn thing I ate when
I slept I worked out as you guys can
tell I tried not to get tan but you
always get tan nothing or a rash guard
it was I was self-conscious of my
psoriasis but the Sun saw water y'all
care that [ __ ] right quick it's better
oh no please put it away nice banner on
please say it's better agree that it's
are you look good bro now come on don't
be don't be dramatic you know it's
better do that
oh no it's bit hey man so you can't
laugh what speaking of health problems
oh you have vertigo yeah I got right now
like the room spinning as we talked
really it's fun for podcasts and driving
it's very safe and so I was like is
there seven lanes so you woke up for
Father's Day
uh well no the day my [ __ ] mom pop shops
in town right now and we
on a hike huh and I took a mad volcanic
mud ball
well it's Mandeville Mandeville Canyon I
don't know how to elevation only a
couple thousand I'm not crazy
so I did that and then instead of going
left I told him to go right and we got
lost for two hours about four and a half
hours hi that's a problem he was not
happy and then no water no food he was
dehydrated and then I felt a little I
feel all right that night then woke up
next more explain it was tiger and then
I was on the ground like wrestling with
him like I do every morning then I
popped up and then the [ __ ] world
sturgis man it could have been something
in your did you do Tiger stickers finger
all the way in your no okay
did you put dirt in your hair no
somebody take a funnel when you were
sleeping and put dirt I'm trying you
have to figure this you know everyone
does have the theory stone somebody
shoot air did somebody take a hose shove
it in your even though wouldn't fit goal
I know like a dolphin yeah did you do
any ear boxing no nobody box your ears
nobody one shot the [ __ ] up with all
your talk like that nobody did not know
everyone at but I went online there's
they go oh it's just act like you're
stretched and put your head towards the
ground for 30 seconds then put you point
your head to the right for 30 SEC yeah a
lot of people have helped a lot of
people have generally help Dana White
said he had the worst vertigo he thought
he was done then he went got stem cells
or now he got something else
it was Meniere's disease alright he got
something yet so he had surgery and it's
an ear canal thing yeah you should go
I'm we go knotek's I'm hoping to be sure
it's a man it's an infection pretty sure
bliss before you go on antibiotics once
you have somebody look at your ear now
take a look at it I'm sure that their
bikes
let me take a look at what's going on
don't just take antibiotics
cures everything well not necessarily
switch over to ear in fact you can scrub
your gut by all
Hey you're such a [ __ ] I got with this
dots always like that's what they think
maybe my gut biome is off and I've been
taking I've been taking that believe
inside but and then I just take it to
bikes and watch it begun no no so I do
don't just take antibiotics trippy dick
antibody well that's different it she
knows antibiotics yeah she got you
throat ain't about no you can't just
keep taking antibiotics you're gonna
create a super bug and then it's gonna
get into me and I'm gonna die sorry man
now I'm gonna take because I travel on
Tuesday I got a busy day tomorrow so I'm
getting him today
really the Ricky little sluggish what
antibiotic are you gonna take are you
gonna dig doctor I think the z-pak do
you have a doctor who looked in your ear
yep okay and wait I say you look a
little red nope he didn't say you got a
red canal nope what types of renders the
doctor I need a Deepak no no your friend
even I don't like your friend right now
your friend needs to go let me look in
your ear we got a red canal now it could
be viral let's wait a couple of days no
not with the ear thing especially a busy
man like me buddy but you have been in
the water that's so strong you were
swimming in river water that was stale
or if you did or you if you were
wrestling in a pond in a stale stagnant
pond my ass my ass is hitch and to I'm
like z-pak did you go to up did you go
to an agricultural farm to go to a pig
farm and you fall into the slop the slop
pool no you sure have you ever had
vertigo no but I feel like I have it
right now and I'm not kidding
I swear guys we're talking I'm dizzy she
had a good thing though you guys you
know I don't know you guys what's
something new you've had you died I like
create them too much oh my god are you
still in the warm embrace you're still
in the warm embrace are you guys both
caught in the warm embrace you're both
still caught right I'm back on it you
[ __ ] guys are whatever I took it this
morning bro
I'm dizzy right now I feel like I'm
having sympathetic vertigo this is
called sympathetic
how about guys were like my wife is
pregnant and I have a sympathetic
pregnancy well get along my friend get
away from you shut your French speaking
about my friend I and the number of
people who I thought were my friends who
are like happy Father's Day bro
friends don't do that go [ __ ] off I
don't know from you man no yep I told
you that site s who my real friends are
who Ted happy fun
we don't know each other and you're
doing polite thing happy Father's Day
that's fine yeah if we're really close
friends we'd only text each other on
holidays man if it's their birthday
I expect the text that's right Christmas
don't text you on Easter bro do not
[ __ ] think oh my god don't touch baby
zombie Jesus they don't thanks God I
agree
god damn it how about this I'm at
Christmas Halloween happy Halloween are
we 14 I could give a [ __ ] you man that's
terrible it's actually offensive
Thanksgiving yeah enjoy yours and mind
keep keep it to yourself
God um real friends I met we had a
bright we had a breakfast and for
Father's Day
nice mine who ie my brother-in-law my
father not myself the whole family
follow mama Brown law they get nice
cards their family prepared them a nice
Father's Day card let's look over at my
wife she's got a blank expression she's
like we have a card my daughter's eye
you guys my daughter I ask the dinners
are I I get a napkin Showtime hey hon a
peon a crinkled a beer there then I'm
not exaggerating
was wet on a corner and kids tickets
shoved at me have asked Idaho and it's
just in crayon happy Father's Day I
can't read it
love Smith it was great lovely thanks
thanks guys
pool effort into a folder that up and
put it in my pocket that's good can you
do it what do you get on Father's Day
anyways nothing and I'm fine yeah make
it and they could have done it be a man
to come up a little bit and I don't love
yourself laughing and daddy yeah a
little so call me daddy dick suck she
get father's a dick sock yeah well dude
it's all good baby what you can plan for
their caucus my [ __ ] is epic apparently
what whoa man what you know married sex
yeah missionary don't look me in the eye
what would you guys do at night [ __ ] no
you weren't okay you're not fooling
anybody at night you know I'll tell you
what I don't you guys do you set up
hotel or air B&B
uh I'm condo okay I'll tell you what is
better
fermius you've been a four seasons shut
your mouth yeah well I'll tell you what
what I did tell you what it's been
I spent a lot of time in Hawaii doing
when I wasn't snorkeling Jack you know
you know I I watched you I never liked
schools I watched parts unknown by
Anthony Bourdain but welcome to 2013 I
knew you'd make fun of me for this but
I'm obsessed with it and I and I know
there's no new ones coming out yeah I
want to go Wow
till we do it I'm just saying I you miss
current events sometimes I didn't know
if there's no new don't there's no
season on everything on oh you knew no I
didn't know if you knew I'm telling
Rogan you just said no God no Tanja I
love go to okay now because you just
said something there was not a tasting
I'm talking I'm good I'm just saying
there's no you see so it makes look at
me no listen to me shame do you pick up
a lynching look at me Cheers oh wow hey
that didn't help
it's nothing Jesus oh wow yeah well you
know what you know what there's no I'm
just saying there's no new host Robin
please I have to well you brought this
on yourself so I'm gonna call the co no
man
yeah all I'm saying is they haven't
selected a new host expect a call from
Joe no it's not a big deal but you'll
have to have a sit-down I'm begging you
I understand you that's Joe's one of my
friends is like hey you're free to talk
I'm like oh yeah what do you want yeah I
don't like when anybody does it hey can
I talk to you nothing ever comes from
that a girl goes we need to talk it's a
nightmare
yeah can we talk it's name yeah sure
what happened it's always so serious I
don't like that I don't like that
no thank you you know you need to be
watching the staircase the documentary
on Netflix oh I heard if like I said
making learners at 10:00 that's about an
8 [ __ ] Soliman really crazy [ __ ] huh
you'd like it what Stephen Amanda what's
loud promise promise says he's a famous
author his wife dies on the staircase he
says he did she fell down they look into
it 20 years previously in Germany a girl
he was very close with died the exact
same way and when they look into it the
exact same death but there's all these
marks on her head like she was hit with
something but she has no skull fracture
their brain damn
so with the biomechanics and the
forensic team they go it doesn't look
like you used anything and she it looks
more like she fell but it's crazy so
what um who is he he's a fair he's a
famous author a chairman offer no no no
he lived in Germany he was the military
but it says what's it just don't like
him Peterson you don't famous officer
Peters read books like yeah
[ __ ] look him up man you've done a lot
of fictional books what's his name uh
Michael Peterson I don't know Michael
I'll look him up on wiki or no ton of
books man favor that crazy crib to like
baller crea does he write thrillers
something I think so well that guy who
[ __ ] drained his girlfriend's blood
who writes gas you know comma see this
is criminal I would I type in Michael
Pearson books for god sakes Jen I heard
this one right I'd just make a piece in
books um see there's a book look at all
this oh wow oh yeah he writes these
thrillers yeah he's a big-time artist
who kills people so anyways how about
the guy who is a graphic novelist in LA
who tortured his girlfriend
Walter three well their three-week old
daughter was in the other room and then
he drained her blood he wrote up he
wrote on a serial killer a serial killer
and then he got caught and they caught
him in in the house got him in the
apartment barricaded well you know this
guy I see it when you get to the end I'm
gonna give you the verdict that they do
they give them but yet to then I was
like I don't know man I do not know
because the whole case the the
prosecution is like he used a fire poker
a fire poker and that I can wear it no
one can find it well the defense finds
it like two days for the verdict they
find it and they test there's nothing on
it so like well where's your what you
got now yeah it's it's interesting why
are you allowed to say okay I don't want
to spoil it for you okay
my jaw was like I was like
okay I think you know but you know what
he is he's unlikable and his brother
who's a lawyer to that right before they
have the verdict they go i pros and cons
in it I'm not saying thing anything
anyone doesn't know but people think
you're slimy they think you're a bad guy
you're arrogant this town has never
really liked you you're the rich white
guy author who thinks he's better than
everyone it's like Jesus Christ oh not
to mention he lived another life where
he would [ __ ] dudes on the side wow
that's that's interesting the best the
funniest part of the whole doc to me
hanging guys yeah he's [ __ ] dudes but
check this out this funny sparked they
bring on his male escort to the stand
and they go you know the court of law
you have to be pretty specific yeah they
go and they're all you know there's
something like sir what exactly were you
trying to do with Mike Peterson and he's
all you know I was a companion and he
paid for my friendship and services and
she goes and what kind of services were
those and goes ma'am anything under the
Sun she was like Zach to that
meaningless should I be like sad judges
should I say it he was sure he goes anal
sex the whole crowd is laughing he goes
in most of time he goes a lot about
there he is he was that same in the with
it he's a soldier good-looking guy
whatever bro so he goes that way he was
most top my clients were attorneys he
goes authors high-powered lawyers and he
goes even judges and then the judge goes
not this judge sorry he was not this
judge in the whole courtroom thread
burst out laughing that's that's crazy
but it's great but then the thing is is
uh in the emails you know he's described
how much he loves his wife he's like my
wife knows I'm bisexual she knows what's
going on here I'm in love with my wife
I'm trying to bust nuts and sometime
people are into that I guess man it I
don't I don't know it's it's a tough one
abeyance to see people watch it what
they say I know uh a man a woman who
used to was married to a guy like that
she would drive him to [ __ ] dudes
yes she would drive him wait in the car
and then he'd come back out that was
their relationship like if your wife was
cheating on you and you found out it was
with another girl I'd way rather have
that I would really
I mean I just wouldn't oh my god get it
well I mean I don't that doesn't make me
jealous would you guys do muff bump make
out would you guys [ __ ] read Twilight
yeah I mean she was the woman and she
was like finger each other laying
whether I'd be like our well but if she
was just gene with you on the side
sucking face I don't give a [ __ ] now if
there's a dude be a different animal
wouldn't it yeah unless she had video I
mean no yeah it would be different but I
wonder how many relationships are like
that where the so that escort was saying
it was most of the time he was in
because the the the prosecution goes so
are you saying that these these other
clients you had what were their emos and
he was all of them were married most
were married men and she goes well gay
married meaning us no matter of fact I'd
say they're more on the straight yep
spectrum games have gay tendency I'm a
fantasy he was but they're straight yeah
so they did psychological profile on
that were you were this is so [ __ ] up
did I talk about this like where how
tell me man be like when when mmm
straight were sexualized at a young age
and they it felt good and it was by a
man but they were straight so what
happens is when they're in a
volatilization or whatever whatever it
might be even though it was full of
shame and you know they were young but
it there was a pleasure involved so they
go back to that they go back to the road
of yeah that that trauma that was also
pleasurable so you can be straight once
a while you like to get [ __ ] by a dude
or you like that you know whatever it is
they said the Spartans would raid towns
and [ __ ] all them dudes and boys they
didn't show that in the movie 300 but
your boy Spartacus any homosexuality was
very very hate to tell you what's the
main guy's name in that I'd had it for a
second I'm Oh what think main guy's
named Tom Cruise no what's his carry
Unitas Lee nice suckin dick no dude dude
leave us watch everyone laid your turn
now suck no nectar have although not
doing the sock in your doing a sake
hey hate to tell you but Leonidas taking
up the pooper no we say yeah that's not
true dude I've done boy no he does he
does he'll walk in certain towns he come
into I think Jamie I do know that the
Greeks in Athens that it was very it was
very acceptable to have a young
boyfriend look at it I think that was
always just gay dudes cuz I you know
most guys were straight I'll take the
girl please I'll take the lady yeah but
back then a lot of them were Ted gate
like a lot of these smart I think
culturally and it's allowed I'd probably
exactly like it is now Isis does to you
know that it's this barbaric lifestyle
like Isis you know every Tuesday's
[ __ ] an American so those American
that go over there they do them in the
boot they get miles of dick
know what it is that's real be well know
what having lived in that part of the
world that this is this is this is one
thing because men and women are
separated in a lot of cultures like that
they're their separate until a very just
you know you're not around women yeah
just what you fellas as you come through
your sexual experimentation there's a
lot of older guys on younger guys
there's a lot of [ __ ] you so no this
becomes kind of accepted to take a
younger dude and under your wing and
then you we I mean your nut and and it's
kind of like a rite of passage there is
that by the way I've heard from pretty
reliable sources that that is also the
case in a lot of upper-class English
like aristocratic know once class know
boarding schools so what do you when the
when the aristocrats when the heiress
actually when the upper-class would send
their children away to boarding school
some as young as six and seven in the UK
United Kingdom a lot of those kids there
it's like Lord of the Flies it's poison
begin boys only girls only separated and
those boys they get to certain age the
older classmates welcome well did you
know most pirates are gay
I don't sir you're making large broad I
swear to god you look like an American
Tuesday look I don't know if somebody
got look up the history of pirates most
pirates are get up there on the ships
non-stop they're always Rancho they
would wear
and points scarves and [ __ ] they just
like me basically yeah I kept Johnny
Depp you tell me a straight man back in
those days was dress yanked up with
mascara I would imagine that they
probably spent a lot of time on boats
and some fighting each other
I'm totally most pirates were over game
is well Orlando Bloom there that he was
definitely get the one getting just
railed by everybody cuz I'd have to
shave that goatee off because he looks
he's gotten feminine features for sure
true story pirates until you look it up
its history from deadly like the rain
briar it's read about pirates I think
that game always existed and they like
beard would tear your ass up now that's
not sure no black ice well gravy bro
dude I sail with a cork I sail with a
large cork in my rump so that's a birth
of gay Buccaneers Tampa Bay gay
Buccaneers yeah and there's nothing
wrong with that I just want you guys to
know most pirates that come in so it's
also an Isis so so in Iraq and Syria
where Isis is is a stronghold Tuesday's
are [ __ ] American yeah and also they
know they right pirates were gay they
ride a train on you bro
uh-huh I'm telling you it says it in the
article but I know this is science this
is history it's his Discovery Channel
guys is history argue with the science
we have graphs okay get on a boat cover
one eye and you want to bang guys their
view if you see a guy with a parrot on
his shoulder and he's covered one eye
with a patch he's he's coming for your
for your honor captain now he's gonna
break your starfish starfish and no one
I'm talking about the starfish at the
bottom of the city man
the only thing pirates weren't taking
with gold and watch your balloon not
nothin like salt they are in a balloon
not nothing like salt they're in an
American's balloon not tell you man yeah
there's a lot of fun my friend who's a
gay [ __ ] he and his boyfriend who lived
together there was a gay gentleman I
want a straight man kids wife on his way
to work he would stop by for coffee and
he's enjoying it he enjoyed getting on
all fours and and and and having being
poked from both ends
he's a married man with kids yes he was
sir you do on his way to work he would
come and he's well looking guy he by the
old tabletop
my my kids they off to school in a suit
and he'd have his briefcase in a suit
what a hassle he would stop and he was
Luba exactly it's exactly
let me see excited remember I was living
there and so it would be what what you
were the guide in certain new math nah
he was nine houses down and he would
stop and say good morning and they'd be
like coffee uh sure thanks so much now
once you warm the mouth up with your
coffee get on all fours
no let's lower those drawers yes and he
and his and my buddy and his gay live-in
lover would would play Oh they create a
[ __ ] he clear with his body they do
my stuff in with cream well it's time to
stop you from both at Boston cream yeah
it's called spit the pig no no it's
called let's make a Long John it's
called spit - let's make any clear yeah
now you're gonna eat we need we no no
it's called a jelly stuffed doughnut
right we're gonna do a spit roast it's
called a spit roast get on the old axle
and spin you around that's what they
would do they would both they would both
and he would just go to work and he'd go
they'd they both spend it's been they've
gift him with their at their essence
there and then he would go thank you
they would drop it with my coffee and my
[ __ ] and I'm gonna see you later
and then he would every day though
apparently was every day no yeah I mean
sometimes I'd skip Sundays sometimes
he'd skip something so that heats up God
give every day yeah sometimes you need
it in the morning
wow what a date way to start your day he
was a straight guy a parallel plate
college football dad this is Colorado
there's some games and play on some guys
that play football but of course there
were some gay guys that played course on
some gay fighters some great wrestlers
damn I can't believe you do that every
day though I can't believe we talk about
gay stuff all the time so many stories
straight
all I said was Pirates used to be gay
you and this has been all you talk about
is how everybody's gay now no I know I
just said pirates you're free of all
these stories you have gave vertigo
dolphins again everybody's gay yes is
becoming theme here
yeah hmm and she now we're at it now
we're out of things to talk about here
now create him chin kratom chin start
his own YouTube page
I know oh you do not go to a chin here
there you know bro cuz I watched it how
do you know bro I need some original
songs bro yeah would you shut up you
know hard that is I don't care I don't
hide your chin yo YouTube page let me
see what's going on here and what do you
put on this you tights I put like some
cooking thing yeah just a little fun
cooking recipes that I have let's see so
when a man loves a chick the [ __ ] that
a man loves a woman I just had to like
put something out because I said I was
gonna be like oh that one you must have
a thousand subscribers bro I know right
that's pretty cool Oh were you out right
now this is my friend Trevor studio
Trevor huh never of him you better bet
cream did you pop before the song none
he wasn't even there you let me borrow
the keys in the studio so there's no
chocolate clear gone no chocolate eclair
so that's just without recording that
was a camera recording and then I turned
on the National audio recording here
[Music]
it wasn't polished the I feel like you'd
go on American Idol on they'd have their
chairs turning around and then they
would flip around like holy [ __ ] the
giant curry
yep yeah and you wear the korean flag i
just huge giant green flag yeah yeah so
you just come you add in more videos
like this and then food videos and just
let me see the grand singers - you got
your workout if kpop is [ __ ] yeah I
mean the kpop they're pretty good but
there's actually a real real singers and
crew that work ethic ulis yeah that work
ethic mmm [ __ ] are you kidding that's
in America Brazil
yeah I've seen it there's so many great
singers you're great go to go to the the
page again what else you get on there
there's really nothing Instagram recipes
let's not put hot dogs in there anymore
that grossed me out happy and then I had
it nope you gotta try at the or spam the
new bikes man ray is like quite
everything Bourdain does so I dunno
it's delicious my cauliflower crust
pizza that was my voiceover music sound
that's the one that I'm most proud of
well go to that do you speak Jewish lion
songs yeah what's up Jen so before I
started working here I I was gonna apply
to a blizzard or bonfire Studios which
is a gaming video games old man but I'm
into like making the voice-over stuff
but I didn't know he's like oh you're
breaking blizzards idq oh you didn't
know no yeah they're like well bonfires
is an up-and-coming one but you're on
the beach a bonfire oh okay but uh so I
did all I'm created all the sound I did
all the voiceover and I did all the
music so everything yeah it has
recreated it you trying to blow up and
leave the podcast
no I'll never leave here I mean not
until the wheels fall off
you create all this everything you hear
so all the music dude why don't you do
this music for a sick ass hype video for
us I'll do it
all this sound you make everything the
only thing that's there is the video so
that's all me
[Music]
[Music]
for this
and then there's like a little change
[Music]
[Music]
kind of scared
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
how'd you make the flame noise chin just
special effects of the fire and sound
design
[Music]
that's fireworks that I recorded
[Music]
[Applause]
this summer Jim war of the world all
that videogame Qin people would play it
Oh world of warfare no world of warcraft
how was what that was yeah bro yeah yeah
that's pretty cool chin thanks man those
animals aren't this this things are
scary mmm oh it's good the moody genetic
movie bombed though huh it did bomb
moves and I think just put so much money
in that movie so expensive
you've heard of war a world left yes um
I wonder if like with genetic
engineering they're gonna be able to
make weird creatures like that
a synthetic biology monsters Brian yeah
synthetic biology they say that the only
thing that's gonna stop you from making
like whatever it won't magically 'men
beings from making what they want so
we'll be able to make dragons and all
kinds of weird [ __ ] you said that if I
was a [ __ ] you wish woody 13 that's the
new frontier creating your own will have
vertigo create some convention maybe
didn't how's your hair doing bro it's
good that man where'd that where was
that picture from the the oh my god
Chris D'Elia posted a pictures no you
look so well help what's going on I was
filing doing my wide smile like yeah I
was doing some crazy find that was that
you and him Sasso had it somewhere I
think I was a long time ago and I was
just doing some weird face right I was
clearly swollen that looks like who's
like the morning before I was growing
beards that's the morning where my face
is all swollen cuz I would drink well
that's the nighttime in the rain
somewhere happy Father's Day this is my
son Bryan Callen
I'm his father in many ways but the most
important thing is I am his father in
the main way meaning I had sex with his
happy Father's Day oh you goddamn [ __ ]
goddamn you to hell the fact you
he said get your here yeah I had it now
please look at my shirt because I have
obviously I have confetti I have notes
rain has to be rain cuz you see it's
raining outside so you must have just
got in the cab or whatever they are
oh my god yeah yeah Wow water tends to
Sparkle on my body the pictures hole
into that face I was like I look like a
human parrot it looks like it oh my
brought the human two cans
Zenon kar I think I'll beat the [ __ ] out
here dude my nose I mean that's a
disaster how dare you both evicted is
such a son of a [ __ ] I think it's a so
Senate to everybody who did it he has
all kinds of [ __ ] he has naked pictures
of me oh who doesn't somebody sent me a
naked picture on my DM of Justin Bieber
somebody hacked ours it's got a keys got
a piece on them that's all it is him on
the roof deck to some yeah yeah yeah
he's in why it's like Belize or
something I'm impressed with this piece
yeah well done kid that's also like I
got these kid these these people hacking
the phones they didn't hack it something
like something happened where it would
know he was he just got done [ __ ]
some hot girl he's on his deck came out
was like stretching I think he knew
there's paparazzi I don't know this
stuff selfie he took oh yeah yeah here
please I don't like I don't approve it
it's not showing I hate the guy I told
the guy said please don't I was like
it's best not to show this stuff you
know if you have these pictures keep
them to yourself especially if they're
of women and stuff I don't I don't think
it's I don't believe in it I feel like a
peeping tom
a peeping that guy looks like a peeping
tom
yeah I find this for you
all righty I'm just looking at birds to
confess you can't see him mm-hmm Oh Oh
the right stuff count looks like a big
bird count up beat you up today hey you
hear me whine [ __ ] no don't call me I'll
shoot he came back on Tommy Bahama yeah
you guys oh that one can't be real right
no yeah what is he looking at again I
did there I think somebody hacked in
this I don't know if the two of them are
counterproof I don't think they're real
these pictures don't just don't show
them to be able be a DIA protector not a
an exploiter it's important man if
you're a young dude I know it's fun to
look at but don't do it man if I don't
think these are real be yeah I hope not
they're not real that one's definitely
not real yeah no that's not real all
right well there we go
is this real my day yes yes what do you
got chin all right the first one is the
news of Chris Hardwick his ex-girlfriend
Chloe Dykstra who he broke up with in
2014 she wrote an article an essay and
she didn't name him in the essay but
pretty modest Lee Hanna super easy so
since that article came out she talked
about certain kinds of abuse and sexual
abuse even so she named him huh she
didn't name him it's so easy to figure
out yeah like when you read the article
I sent to you guys when you read Arkans
it's pretty easy figure I have a problem
with anybody who airs their laundry
publicly like this in the public square
personally if you have a problem with
somebody confront them deal with it
wouldn't hurt her intentions
what's his revenge well her exact
intentions were to get him fired from
his show that night like that's the only
reason you do otherwise you dress it
one-on-one right that's exactly cuz your
intentions are to hurt the hottest new
dealing with so then that Dan
Massena so mission accomplished but I
don't know where you go Congrats girl so
when you read it though like she goes oh
you know people can read this go why
don't you just leave him once you just
do this you should just not put up with
it but whose fault is that I know it's a
self-esteem issue but you have to take
responsibility for that question so my
age when I first read it I went okay and
she goes he he listed off these rules
from day one so he didn't drink so he
told me not to drink he told me that he
works all during the day so I need be
there at night when when he's there
okay and he listed the rest he's real
snow talking at dinner be ready for sex
when I get home from work and right off
the bat she says he was like this so I
go I well if I'm dating someone that I
predict ant drink and I like to drink
like I'll [ __ ] you and maybe it's a
self-esteem issue or whatever you
stories you have to own that there's
response to that situation you're in
that's you personal responsibility and
and part of like when you get taken
advantage of like this when you get
bullied when you're abused and all of us
have been taken advantage of there are
just different degrees right some people
obviously it's very but emotional and
you go through that when you go through
that the idea is you can choose to be a
victim from it or you can get stronger
and learn a lesson from it and and you
know so when when do you take
responsibility for it whatever whether
these are allegations okay so I'm not
gonna say yes or no I don't want to get
him
I know it's death by allegation now I
know it's death by accusation I think I
have a problem with that too but I'm not
gonna I'm gonna leave that to slide I
don't I know Chris for a long time here
there's no hurt you're screwed because I
read it I've read the rules on Mike
right so he's an [ __ ] that's fine if
that's what he treats women not saying
that's fine but that's his deal he also
has some issues the way he treats women
if not good if those are all true not
good he's an [ __ ] all right not my
type of dude I'm off the train she lose
all his jobs probably not then I kept
reading it well he blackballed her from
getting work so she worked for his
company he got her fired from that yeah
and then for the rest of the gut jobs he
made sure she didn't get my question is
this that's from one person and their
accusation there has to be something
something close he says yes
but she's saying she has concrete the
companies that have fired him have proof
or did they just fire the problem based
on accusation we are seeing this all the
time just know that in that environment
you are next know in that environment
which is remember it's not what you
think it's how you think it's really
it's really methodology to me when if
you're a MC or if you're comic-con so if
he comes on does actually she hit me she
had these rules how is that any
different so is she gonna loose whatever
job she has because what we can't do is
let's say he did all the stuff and he
blackballed from being work stuff like
that all right he should be disciplined
lose some of those jobs we don't know
who though right so when you just post
that and then AMC never goes up he's out
like you know what if she's lying right
we live in a time now where an accuser
right or wrong all the power lies there
and that your entire livelihood can be
destroyed off of an accusation without
due process and that's what it looks
like and that is very dangerous and I
was I will also say this so she will say
oh I'm doing this to help others I'm
doing your solely doing this to affect
his work yeah and to gain some sort of
notoriety and phantom core let's be real
of course because if you want to have
there's other ways and go about the
course and mainly to confront somebody
on your own terms as opposed to airing
this all out in the public square this
was just trying to hers was Rivard wish
now and maybe maybe she you know we
don't know the story right so maybe
there was a situation where she was she
was screwed over and she's getting back
but that's what this is this is what
she's left out of her thing to does she
cheated on him see again I don't know
when he had this now what I not what I
do know is if he did those things
terrible person right that's [ __ ] up
do you an [ __ ] get away from that but
you should leave so you got to take that
responsibility but also she cheat on him
and according to Chris his records he
goes she cheat on me I broke up with her
she begged for me back and he goes she
was telling me she wants to marry me
wants to have kids with me he goes if I
was that bad to her she was saying I'm
the one
once once Geum Gina I lost all faith in
her so I don't want to get back with it
there are two sides of the story right
there's two sides of the story and the
truth and nobody's lying or everybody's
lying who knows the bottom line is a
middle there are two sides of the story
right now we live in an environment
where when you're accused you lose
everything and that is very dangerous
and also we're also at a point where I
think that that you know you I don't
care what your situation is you are
responsible personal responsibility has
got to take precedence over everything
else I don't care
you're responsible we are all
responsible for the condition where is
it yes people suffer from abuse yes they
get into a situation where we're it
they're overwhelmed where they can't get
out of it of course of course it still
doesn't take away that with the idea
that personal responsibility is crucial
into an adult and there's all no
physical like you know hitter's but also
she put these were just a so she lists
all the rules I wasn't allowed to take
pictures of them and this is all from
the jump so the rules are very clear
from the jump again I don't condone it
he's an [ __ ]
if this is true so she but these were
just a few of the rules and I made the
choice to accept his controlling
behavior and this is her justifying it
as he just left his long-term girlfriend
and I assumed that he was going through
some serious emotional discomfort that
was a huge mean the what she's saying is
that when you're being abused and you
see this with women or getting the [ __ ]
beat out of them by their husband they
will make excuses for their abuser
career it's very very common it's very
human you know a lot of times with
people who've been abused when they were
kids or they were neglected or whatever
they will find ways because they have
very low self-esteem to justify the
abuse of course and that is something
that has to be worked on it still
doesn't take away from the fact that
when you go through that you have to
reset and as you get older maybe she's
doing this now she's taking you have to
take responsibility it'll never happen
to me again or I recognize this and I'm
telling young girl not to accept this
and all that stuff right there's value
in this example right so my daughter
will be told about something like this
my daughter will from me I'll always be
like if a dude's treating you like this
you can't the [ __ ] out now I'm her dad
some women don't have a dad someone feel
like piece of [ __ ] at the end of the day
though it's up to all of us to figure
a way to take responsibility I only
issue with this is that I I just have a
problem with anybody airing this out
publicly like this well my issue is it
destroys my I again if this is all true
from her side
all right [ __ ] you probably should
lose his job
however by him losing his job before we
hear his side of the story
or what we know is true yeah that's so
[ __ ] up horse and it's happening all
the time and just remember we all of us
are next and in one way or another this
has happened to women how many times
it's happened to women in history she's
a [ __ ]
what yeah yeah she's a [ __ ] she [ __ ] a
lot of guys a boss could just
blackballed a woman and did it all the
time and she shouldn't get a job oh I
seen did this [ __ ] work or not her
careers over Hardwick did this according
to her and there's some pretty hard work
did this to her so she couldn't work in
him okay
yeah but the problem is is we don't know
who's true but how we don't know what's
true and then he loses jobs is insane
yeah but also we have to be a little
wary with this whole me too thing a lot
of people are doing it for attention
don't get it twisted like oh they're so
brave up brave shirt but they're doing
it for some sort of notarize you're
always gonna have people like this of
course what else you got Jim speaking of
notoriety for that I don't know if you
guys heard this but Jamie Foxx has an
allegation against him that he slapped a
woman with his penis and this happened
she says in 2002 at a Oscar party
afterwards like she said that when she
refused to give him oral sex he he
slapped her with his penis so it so let
me see
so sixteen years ago was she's trying to
sue me for word that's the thing so
statute of limitations are over if
anything I guess you would have to be
suing him for wylie something right
that's - it's like somebody says this
now this is news I don't understand like
what do you what maybe honestly anybody
can say anything and it makes of the
news people look at this because it just
sounds funny yeah that's the reason why
I clicked on them nothing's gonna happen
I mean yeah there's no police report
filed then or just not
there's no evidence at all other than
she's saying this yeah all right all
right girl okay okay well you were you
looking for a new gig 16 years later
whoa I don't understand why you're
coming forward now it's so strange to me
but all right
and of Oscar party you had your dick out
and you slapped her so what was your
head did you jump up on the table
I'm so confused that's a good point too
I mean I don't even know how to respond
what else she had Jim all right
this my buddy Quan said to me it's about
a clarinetist who was supposed to be
this amazing clarinet I wanted to get a
dream job or a dream opportunity with
his mentor he looks like your boy hunter
month yeah keep going - all right so so
what'd she do so he he did this test for
up this huge clarinetist teacher guy
right that only gets like two two
students a year and then they're the
ones that get like 76% his graduates or
70% 6% of all the clarinetists that do
all the Big Show's right so he did the
test and he actually got accepted so the
guy emailed him that if he wants the
opportunity to train under him the girl
who was living with him at the time she
didn't want him to leave and move over
to where he was going so she intercepted
that email she wrote a fake email saying
he wasn't accepted Wow she's now been
ordered to pay three hundred and
seventy-five thousand Canadian dollars
which is I think about what is it there
in 50 thousand 50 thousand dollars mmm
three hundred seventy five thousand
Canadian dollars and damages and legal
fees so no so he found out later years
later he auditioned again for that guy
all right and the guy's like why are you
coming back here already you already
turned me down once and then that's when
you started figuring out like this girl
did it to him he already had broken up
with her at that time but she says mr.
AB ramadas didn't give up on his dream
image in 2016 he traveled to California
to audition a second time with the
professor who's confused had this dude
already turned
the opportunity to work with him that's
when the story begin unravel Wow Wow
that's that Tim yep let's play it um he
doesn't really seem all right you don't
play that
Wow what a bummer split now he's working
with him he's working with him but the
teacher said like you know he's a great
kid and everything he's perfect he would
have went way further if he would have
been there if he lost like two years of
his clarinet life right because of this
damn you know those buddies with them
now it's clear that those guys just I
mean bragging say you don't know I'm the
next wagon Oh what does that mean they
fly to the morgue into them it's
reinforced
see ya clarinet will bring you to your
knees dude you might you might be on
stage with some gram amazing clarinet on
I want Brendan to watch and I want to
see what happens to his eyes try not to
cry [ __ ] dare you
dude he lost two years of clearing our
life yeah yeah ready yeah that one I'll
do Britain Got Talent yeah bring out Tom
yeah hit that Britain's Got Talent
hit that clarinet oh he's hot I've never
married an aqua no children
he said he's never been married no
children feed on the inside he's got a
counter standardized pleasure for me but
you would like to do professionally NDF
Li and practice my clarinet and it
basically takes away all the distress
from the everyday work and activity it's
thought more deeply is that your music
yes I'd say this makes me sad but I love
amongst anesthesia probably very
privileged to play the Royal Variety
Performance the opportunity would be
basically out of this world
he's probably I feel so bad for Hank
Reyna is a passion yeah I feel therefore
I love that I'm scum glad he has Karen
oh that's a big deal hello Sam
welcome what's your name please James
Shields hello James and how are you 15
15 and then we're 15 but it sounds like
she's gonna count friends that's a
surprise it's single single well that
could all change what made you take up
the clarinet basically we're not start
your secondary school I was introduced
to it by my music teacher he told me to
practice it I played it for a couple of
days I enjoyed the sounds and it went on
from there and do you play with it every
day my practice McLeod it most days yes
once a day yes Brett yes how long I
James what would you like to happen if
you did well on the show I like the
opportunity perform it to lots more
people let's give them the enjoyment and
a pleasure that I receive from the views
they can pass it on today he's a
beautiful human being thankful I love
this guy
[ __ ] remembers laughs I know but it
makes me so would Webber he's a good guy
relax ma'am you're a bully and you would
shove him in the corner no I would not
man
Chemical korjev's
[Music]
it's a tough fence right if it tough
instruments here we go
hey there you go yeah hey watch peers
ago next
I love Piers Morgan
[Music]
[Applause]
hold steady brother
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a tough instrumental time where
it's careful they say love I love them
[Applause]
be it stop it Jen there's being cool now
yeah the clarinet well what does simon
say about it let me just say let me see
what he says it's long it's too long my
accountant put me into a nice trance I
found it quite pleasant actually
thank you very much the audience
definitely turned in your favor just
because of these barbaric use of the
buzzer halfway through we blew your head
off
I think about that you've been
disgraceful in front of James James I
just didn't find your clarinet very
entertaining yes or no yes thank you see
I leave is anyone else they would say
yeah I know but he's you feel so
painfully modest and he's a gentle
spirit he's a gentle spirit
Simon James like you I'm going to say
I'm gonna say no I'm afraid that's a no
and Simon there's no way man Jesus
that's so mean
no it's not like it was he goes it's
just one of those instruments yeah
sightings like dude I'm I'm making this
[ __ ] I'm looking for town you to book
a venue like yourself one of those where
are you gonna put that where well I'm
watching and I'm like I wanted I was so
buddy you know that song is if you
didn't feel bad for me you wouldn't even
tolerate that that's a great song you
know what that song is Ave Maria yeah
you know what movie does that very well
for ten points Raging Bull Robert De
Niro in the beginning of that movie kind
of [ __ ] in slow motion Oh about Jake
LaMotta one of the best movies of all
time for aging bull what else you got
Jim if you haven't seen that get it
under your I didn't see it I gotta watch
it bro oh yeah I have no suggestions Kim
Kardashian Kardashian recently said when
she was asked about like possibly
running for president I don't know why
you're entertaining this she says never
say never
I'm me hey she did something pretty
amazing though like she got leniency for
that one prisoner but without a life
sentence job maybe she was way smarter
than we give her credit for oh I think I
do think she's smarter than we give her
credit for I think she's more than just
an ass and some great titties
I do yeah you know the Empire she's
built but I don't want to run to my
goddamn country I got yeah what else you
got chin all right this is actually
pretty funny so the South Korean coach
for the World Cup because people in the
audience he believes that might be the
other team watching he had people his
players have multiple numbers on their
jerseys because he believes that like
Swedish people or Westerners can't
really tell the difference between Asian
faces so it confuses me crashed so from
a distance no let's be general it's just
it's just reality I mean too much
Austria there's tons of Asian people in
Australia that's where they go to
vacation yeah I like chin do you know
what their sayings like no man they're
Chinese are like oh yeah
Mike Jin do you know what to say is like
they're Japanese
Michael I learned you did like by then I
was like dude yeah Korean Japanese my
cry yeah my um
Taekwondo teacher my Korean Taekwondo
teacher was an amazing guy but I'm so
racist he'd be like about white people
he'd be like you know this is the first
time he like he said he found all white
people when he first came to this
country is like the first of all they're
all smell like wet chicken like I know
you guys and you guys and you guys
always say that we sound like ching
chong ching chong he goes yeah you guys
sound like this cha cha cha cha cha
that's what he was sound like to him he
was I refuse to learn he goes I know F F
is that you know that he would say F is
instead of me using hip-hop as I'm young
times I'm all you know with all the
times I mama training I'm crazy practice
you know and but he would say he had an
accent and he's like I know how to speak
your language but I don't have any
respect for it so [ __ ] off
he was so [ __ ] amazing wet chicken
racist okay you know when I came here
bro yeah yeah yeah chin all right this
is a I don't know if you guys have seen
this illusion yet but I thought was
pretty crazy
have you seen this illusion first of all
no okay so it's basically just a brick
wall okay um see do you see anything in
there hold on I feel a little black ball
it's not the brick wall okay see you a
little ball inside but bro I'll rock the
rock yeah hold on do right well so
that's an illusion this is this is just
a picture but there's an illusion in
there so there's a regular normal
picture but once you see the illusion
you'll never not see it okay play it you
guys repeat Brian you let's take a guess
or nah they're so so something in there
doesn't exist
yeah but it looks like some something
does look like something in there is it
so this is a close-up right now I'm
looking at a brick wall brick wall
you're saying it could be something
other than brick wall I don't want to
give too much away but there's there's a
there's a thing there something's there
that will you'll see after I oh I see it
what it's a cigar yeah I I stare this
forever I couldn't get it do you see it
right now
watch you're gonna do this that that's a
security guard with the ash right there
and that's a cigar do you see it yeah I
guess no a lot question watch do you see
it now you let me make it bigger then
it's just a picture so come on bro
so are you the goddamn to go yeah see
here's a cigar you see you'd be yeah or
no no I see it that it's yeah so just
make sure look at the texture of it -
all right there's like little wrapping
here and there now it's gone now I see
it yeah and now you'll always see it
yeah originally it just looks like it oh
[ __ ] crazy alright yeah that's really
good why did I see it before go bad I
know what why did it take me like a few
seconds wait to go back now hmm how are
you I mean that's so funny I didn't see
it and now you do that it was good to
just see it yeah I can't believe you saw
it I could not figure it out I guess
your eye has to be on one specific spot
in the picture I don't know how it works
but all I see is that cigar now yep or a
glory hole that's that Craven man you
guys are in the warm embrace now are you
how many of you taking a day yeah imma
stop taking because I have [ __ ] uh
vertigo ready to go yeah but those
who've been sitting on the table there I
know I don't have no desire to take them
anymore alright what else you got Jim
cool this one a tug of war between three
I guess they're pro wrestlers yeah oh
you did crazy yeah yeah this some people
think it's fake I can't tell I can't
like prove it all weird is the rope goes
like yeah but they do this often I guess
they do yeah hmm tigers lions but what
people yeah but you think the people
there would be able to tell it's fake
that's it just so it's not a huge lion
with your well you have that that see
how there's a crank in that rules like
that that's legit I don't know because
maybe the Tigers just I don't know that
rope will curved like that ain't legit
lying tug-of-war I'll hold that
all those guys off I think there's other
videos see there's one here too with a
bunch of kids and this is more straight
well well that's a male lion biscuit
well a whole bunch of them oh it's just
dominating they're not doing terrible
they're doing better in the fight so for
kids and wanted dog and the line just
kind of [ __ ] around
al strong yeah yeah there and that's not
that big of a line mm-hm I'm drawing a
500 pound male lion Brennan to be quiet
about lions you don't know anything
about lions Wildlife's ago all right I
mean I've done this with a dog do a pit
bull [ __ ] you just like dogs I can
take a pit bull that was like bolted on
yeah that's that's ridiculous
oh no that's the ball to not make a
breakthrough all the way so you don't
get yeah yeah yeah so don't rip your
[ __ ] face off yep they're so hard man
go free we're gonna say cheese okay
RUP let's go piss hard I'll secure your
hips
well we piss hard and true my friend I
feel I could get away to a few seconds
to wrap the show right now but sometimes
and you gotta go you gotta go when you
gotta piss is strong and hard you gotta
piss right that's right like a supercell
you wait you wait how much now 3:30
yeah you're big around 3/3 like you're
bigger than I've ever seen you muscular
thanks man
what are you doing eating a lot of just
lifting weights its vertigo you do
Palatine you get bigger I no problem I
lift weights and I get smaller
you look like a frog off neophytes
bothing I lift all the time nothing
grows I just don't put on muscle I'm a
small your skipper getting ripped
I'm nothing I got nothing I don't know
man [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you don't know boy I'm back from Hawaii
Oh
ie brah why bro oh I'm off to Texas B I
know you are you going to Houston this
Friday I'm gonna be in Houston I'm in
Houston Friday Saturday to Joe's Friday
to show Saturday Houston improv and the
next show will be Saturday July 7th
Cherokee Casino Oklahoma I'm doing my
stand-up and then I'm sticking around
watching the fights with you guys the
one ticket gets you into my stand-up
show and the fights that's July 7th tak
calm for tickets now I'm in Spokane July
12th through the 14th Spokane Washington
get them Bryan town we're gonna be your
Thursday human Conoco this Thursday
Friday Saturday giving a comedy club
come see me and then I want you to come
see me and I'll be in Syracuse and I'll
be in Tampa at the improv right before
hey Brian and Brian July 19th tire Hall
in Chicago but this weekend
come see me I'm not gonna say it again
Berlin helium yeah I want to sell out
nothing Garston yeah if I can get joke
tickets [ __ ]
this the fun kid we're out